the harvard graduate school of education
working at the nexus of practice, policy, and research
Being a blind teacher in a public school
I didn't, to be perfectly frank, see it is any
big deal
I mean I knew it wasn’t all that common.
I just knew we had two things in a different
way and have my classroom set up in a way that we were a
community
I actually have three degrees.
The EDM in nineteen sixty nine, a CAGS in 1971
and an EDD in nineteen seventy six. The time I spent here at Harvard was wonderful.
since we’re doing an all black cover with just brail,
we wanted to have the photos
match
the tone of the cover, and have, kind of, the dramatic
photo with just David
really lit
we thought that would make it dramatic and really emphasize our whole point
when you’re taking the shot and you want me to keep my head in a certain position
maybe, turn from left to right
if someone can stand out in that direction
because I can’t focus on a spot on the wall
so if I have a voice to focus on, that helps
let’s look at a couple, there might be some there where his chin is down
let me just have you
with your shoulders squared
and there is something with your hands, they weren’t gripping it tightly
they were very relaxed…once I start pointing it out to people
they get all self conscious about it
I’m going to have you just square your shoulders to me…perfect. Now back to position.
we’re all set.
brings back good memories, being in this building. It really does. It was a wonderful time.
I had a very full and enriching experience.